[Music]
[Music]
yes we did cause we back at it again
fire
stop
[Music]
this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby I gotta hide all your stuff
go ahead just go just go he's gotta hide
his Ferrari key all that stuff dude just
because you're in the cars isn't your
fault and fashion I I was saying that I
feel like that's from Peru that's a
bandana that's what comes on bandanas
what this is that is that does look like
it's from Mexico and and they took
bandanas that nobody wanted and they
turned it into a quilt and then nobody
wanted the quilt and then they turn it
into a button-down Poncho is that fair
that's fair okay that's fair remember
when we'd wear bandanas as masks when
Ellie Mays wear masks yes and then they
said you're not allowed to do that
anymore dude
yeah now Daddy had to do the podcast
early today because you're headed to
Detroit going to Detroit shoot a movie
it's gonna be warm there it's gonna be
super warm there it'll be nice I gotta I
gotta pack me a thick old down jacket
and then I I heard go to eight mile well
I heard downtown Detroit's super nice
it's a bunch of hipsters no there's
parts of the trailer really cool yeah
but you know you want to have your head
on swivel if you go to eight miles seven
miles if you don't know somebody email
one through eight go ahead and stay at
them I say as they say who you rolling
with no you gotta call you gotta check
in that's it you got to check yeah check
in dude like I didn't know this David
goes I forget it's on my Instagram too
Dave goes uh all this Blah Blah's coming
to show I'm like I don't know hip hop
he's like hip-hop he's like no this guy
runs Houston like if like if you're one
of the guys like rapper whatever you
check in with this guy like he's Mr
everyone yeah I didn't know him he's
right there he was so nice there you go
now I have we gotta check in yeah you
got to check so if you didn't come to
Houston you know how like when you play
Denver you always check in with me right
because I don't want I don't want you
getting messed up I don't want the boys
beating you so you got to make sure I
got your perimeter around yeah I'm like
well and I I let every all the all your
Ops know right you don't know what that
means no I don't I let the Ops know
hands off hands off otherwise dad's
gonna lay down the game well that's like
frankly that's like Houston quick story
about Frank Grillo in tepito Mexico
where uh that's the cartel stronger
you'll go to tepito unless you know
someone now Frank decided to as they
were shooting to stroll the marketplace
and pick up some trinkets for a Spam
yeah okay they need that what he didn't
realize that Max was an elephant well he
didn't realize what is that in tepito
you got Lookouts everywhere
and it got it got to the one the main
one of the main guys hey your boy's just
wandering the street
they found him touch sweet and they were
like hey hey you can't do that but I'm
an actor you gotta roll with us which
means you got to be with us there's some
parts like that in America I mean
there's sure obviously that that's not
excuse but David said yeah like if
you're in that world you're checking
with this guy checking who's such a nice
guy oh so he's he's he's the guy you
check in he's rolling he's rolling he
goes Instagram you'll see him he's on
there with P Diddy I mean oh okay he's
with that guy who who recently got shot
and killed from the Migos take off no no
the guy is the real deal so now he was I
get it this dude's Charisma yeah yeah I
was like holy he was so nice really yeah
there he is with P Diddy so now now hold
on that's genuine Chin's favorite so
hold on he's he's the [ __ ] so he runs
that town it's like whatever you have
some problems you ever see people did
Pete uh Snoop Dogg talk about with nas
he goes Naz got people with him I mean
he ain't got people with him but he got
people with him if you know what I mean
yeah like I was like he couldn't sound
any wider there but yeah no I sound a
lot like no he mean people I mean people
I don't know what that means but he uh
he got like but if you're in those Arch
those dark arts you gotta you can't just
come through L.A you gotta check in
especially check in if you're in that
world you gotta check him with a shot
caller you gotta shock the shot color
yeah well it's like when I shot on that
movie uh I mean I think we were up for a
few uh Oscars that movie
um that I shot with Shia LaBeouf yeah
probably one of the worst movies all the
time but they shot it in the tax man
yeah they shot that in straight Hood but
their security was all gang bangers yeah
and then the director's like yeah in
order to shoot here we have to get it
clear to them like not the city goes no
no no no no so all the security was
gaming this is there this is their they
run it yeah yeah they run it well
speaking of which and I don't want to
get my security out
I don't want to get who I roll without
yeah because I got people I mean I don't
have people here but I got people if you
know what I mean right and
I was wondering how you want to get that
five thousand dollars to me let's enter
the uh the cash app the night once you
text me I said I didn't get it yeah yeah
I do I didn't see that yes I got it you
sent it to me I sent it now there's a
limit on there so it's going to come in
that's what I mean now here's the pro I
knew it I I need listen to me now here's
not what did you send me because I don't
like getting paid in increments well the
juice is running but here's this is not
here's the thing you ain't trying to do
double nothing right you don't want that
problem you don't want 10 G's you know
what's better than five ten hold on you
know spending five I already got some
money in my account I said Court you
just told me you sent it did you or did
you that's what I'm saying but we could
do double enough on this next one
you mean the rematch the Remake they're
gonna rematch they're not gonna
they're not gonna give us period like
you want me to break down I'll break
down well I was I was I was batting a
thousand on on Saturday I I had Poirier
for a lot of reasons on that I mean that
was we'll talk about that yeah not so
much a toss-up that first round was yes
yeah you're talking about a crazy
athlete explosive that that dangerous
could have been a 10-8 round yeah and I
want to get your table it comes out like
a band yeah I I want to get your I want
to get your objective take on my
assessment on Chandler Poirier in a sec
but I'm gonna say this about Izzy Pierre
so so for me what it looked like was
pierra Izzy was winning that fight three
to one yes easy but I think a lot of
that was Pierre saying this is a five
round fight I don't want to guess I have
a big weight cut he was definitely
reserved yep I'm gonna sit here watching
this Fuel and then in a way five minutes
for a guy like that's a long time you
know for a pier yeah yeah super long you
know what I mean even he got rocked in
that first round first round if there's
30 seconds left
the buzzer it was a straight right and
then he rolled that right and then he
stopped
he rolled that right well he stopped and
then
he put his hands down and got caught
well no no no don't discredit it is he
landed straight and then the bell went
Bing but the most the left hook was
already in motion he was wobbled from I
would disagree with that I watched it I
disagree but that's okay either way
either way um I think that you have a
situation where para is clearly a
[ __ ] natural 205er she's enormous
he's enormous he's got legs and ass for
days you should go 205 would be a better
fit for him to be honest because I
thought to myself
I I I mean I'll tell you how I think
Izzy beats him but but here's I thought
to myself and it's what I bet on him I
was like he's gonna get is he ultimately
against that it's a huge 30-foot [ __ ]
cage I get it but he's gonna get him
against that fence and he's gonna bang
and when he bangs you know it's just
laws of physics I'm always going to take
the bet I'm always going to take the guy
who's and by the way his level of
striking he's a two-time glory belt
holder in glory that's a huge deal so he
got better as well it's not like he
didn't get better his kickboxing got
evolved too MMA striking involved not
his kickboxing but is that a May strike
yeah but but with those gloves those
small gloves so that's why I'm a
different animal yeah yeah but having
said that I think Izzy can still beat
him oh yeah and as you can still beat
him because of the weight cut and I
think what he should do is just [ __ ]
kick his body keep his [ __ ] front
kick is he just putting cruise control
off this round he wins he's a world
champion but you know that's not is he
styled would you say also this though
would you say so I would say kick the
body keep the body kick him in that
[ __ ] solar plexus he's coming in like
that just kick him kick him he's going
to run out of you know he's he's already
gonna go affect this card is playing for
those later and then ultimately wouldn't
you tell him to wrestle him yeah he
looked really bad on the ground right
yeah it's almost like dude shoot a blast
double but the rematch would be
interesting and they there you have the
odds out is he still a slight favorite
barely like minus 120. that's
interesting to me but if you think about
it that fight like again if Izzy let's
say they read and I don't think the
rematch will look the same but they
redid that fight is he won the majority
of the fight so that's with us but
wouldn't you say that's because pajera
was so reserved well that's what I'm
saying like I think in the rematch Pier
is going to be a little more foot on the
gas because he was very reserved and was
like hesitant so was Izzy yeah they were
both pretty hesitant to izzyland the end
of the round but they're just kind of
fitting each other out Pierre hasn't
been in that big spot is he's doing his
thing you know so I think Pierre never
fighting in five rounds was like let's
see how it goes yes I think he's come
forward that being said if you do open
up like that you're liable to get hit I
think you should go up to 205. he'll be
a 2005. because because um he's not
afraid of his he's power it seems he's
just not he's just not we're worried
about no he gets close he was doing a
lot with it he was controlling his hands
so is he couldn't do much there but he
was into even the clinch I guess he was
in close quarters he's even better so he
wasn't doing a lot I thought they're
gonna get there the UFC has to do the
Remake you can't you know he is he he
lost that fight he's what what defended
about five times that had been his 13th
win in a row so when a guy has that long
of a Reign they have to admit a rematch
also in order to protect Alex Pierre you
have who else you can toss them like
comes out was like all the guys who can
grapple they want him so oh please
please the easiest way to become
champion because if you when they were
grappling granted is he should have done
it more but when they were grandpa I was
like God damn what was like a white belt
blue belt I was like this is not what
I'm but when you saw when you saw Izzy
throw the leg in right remember when
Pierre was on his four off Force like
was there a body lock opportunity there
was there a double sure that's why I'm
saying there's a lot of room to take
advantage that's not letting you up
at 85. well then this is the thing so
the the respectable thing to do is to
give Izzy the rematch them to his thing
then if Alex beats him there then it's
you know then you just gotta do your
thing and toss them to the other bad
matchups but so they will do that I do
think they give uh is he the rematch but
if depend what they want to do with
homzite and homs that's asking for it
there's a reason why Whitaker Victoria
everyone's like because yeah they saw it
yeah everyone saw it yeah and he's
getting tired on the ground wrestling
everyone's all oh my God this would be
the easiest way to become world champion
yeah
he does that fast leg kick those little
leg kicks that Dutch style where he
doesn't turn his hips over because
they're they're dead you're gonna count
it because you get counted right because
Dutch people are so big that they
they're worried about hands right is
that what it is yeah but that same thing
for heavyweight for you guy like you
that's why no you guys can turn it over
you just gotta you know you gotta be out
of the way get your head off the center
but also those leg kicks did he is yet
but the one that affected you the most
was actually Izzy throwing the kick that
Pierre checked he said it messed up his
whatever that perennial now he said he
was like that's compromise but he was
like that's why I love Izzy like this is
how you should deal with the loss he's
like hey better man
I'm worried about what he was saying
medically I wonder what's going on
what'd he say he said he's dealing with
some medical issues and people are
calling me skinny but they said the same
thing about Chadwick Bosman and he had
cancer yeah I know and I was like oh no
I don't like hearing that well yeah that
kind of [ __ ] might be a hormonal that's
what he's saying some guys get from
smoking too much weed like the THC like
there's a million things
that's not even that but it's tough on
your body was used to that there's a lot
of guys that lose weight but then also
like you have a buddy who you know I
have the carpets with he's
I don't know 38 and just got he has a
lump and just diagnosed with breast
cancer dude yeah that's right it is a
lump let's take a little break because I
know you're well rested and and you seem
well rested I want to know what your
secret do I because I look tired no you
look tired I am kidding so when you need
sleep when you're traveling well dude on
the road you know how it is falling
asleep after shows what do you take no
Daddy I'm using that next Evo Naturals
CBD they have one CBD that's just for
sleep dude after we get absorbed oh my
God I pass out I pass out because next
Evo they got me covered man right there
at the technology you actually absorb
more CBS it's called smart sorb
technology yes sir yeah cbd's ability to
be absorbed and in as little as 10
minutes I'm telling it really calms me
down that's evil natural scientifically
formulated to deliver more CBD in a way
your body can actually use it clinically
proven to have a four times better
absorption rate four times better yeah
dude to help your body have a healthy
inflammatory response try the the new
revive CBD complex which adds benefits
all right of course
CBD we got you guys man don't sell for
less there's a lot of weird CBD out
there this is one I actually use it's
the one product I bring on the road with
me get your supply of next Evo Naturals
revive CBD complex today or shop their
gummies capsule capsules
capules proven to absorb four more times
faster than regular CBD oils faster get
up to 25 off when you subscribe and
spend 40 or more at next evo.com recover
with promo code fighter that's next e x
t e v o.com slash recover promo code
fighter hey B you ever been at the gas
station like that Rhino 5000 erection oh
yeah you take that it I don't know
what's in there you don't know what's in
there if you're gonna buy your erection
pills from a gas station you probably
deserve what you get but there is a
company Joy mode they will save the day
okay you're trying to bring some joy to
your to your love life man it's like a
pre-workout for sex that's the best way
to describe it yep yep yep yep I'm with
you man and joy mode has no nasty side
effects they're here to save the day
whether you're happy or unhappy with
your performance in the bedroom why not
perform a little better get that
performance of the night bonus from your
girl Joy mode sexual performance
boosters like a pre-workout but as Brian
said for your dick game it's natural and
science backed it's a sexual Wellness
product okay it supports erection
quality and firmness and sexualize
contains clinically supported doses of
l-citrulline arginine yohimbe and
vitamin C uh and I guess it was created
by Best in Class sciences and biochem
mystery phds oh wow so there you go how
to take it all you do you tear it open
all right you mix it with six to eight
ounces of water just like whatever your
Electro light Patrick packets you guys
take all right and what if you're trying
to spice it up you're trying to add a
little Turbo get that performance of the
night from your girl in the sack and do
it all natural without prescription
drugs we have a special offer for the
find the kid audience go to
usejoymode.com fighter enter fighter at
checkout you get 20 off for that Wiener
that's usejoymode.com Fighter for twimp
stop for your first order thanks Joy
mode do we know how Rumble Johnson died
yeah yeah he had a that's way too hard
to just to give the name of the actual
scientific name no no no it's hard at
all his white blood cells were attacking
his organs and the red blood cells oh
man so you have a 50 if you have it yeah
Olympus yeah lupus but with something
else where the white blood cells attack
the organs usually have some diagnosis
say three months to live dude and then
you have a like 50 percent chance to
live but it's super rare in adults
can I see that yeah it's non-hodge uh
not what do you call that oh yeah
oh no it was attacking us really his
biggest issue was the liver [ __ ] dude
this is
fine and we had him on food truck and
what's a bummer's dick boy posted it and
I post it when you post it and tagged
him then brings up your old DMS so it
had the conversation with him for like
three months ago just talking because
that's insane dude insane did you have
any idea oh yeah yeah he's close friends
no I didn't know it was this bad but he
was like yeah this thing's not good but
I don't think he even you know he's a
fighter man so they're all we'll be able
to beat this guy man 38 dude 38 38 I
worked with him on Warrior good dude so
I remember when I I was with him spent a
lot of time with him he was uh 230
pounds and he was gonna suck down the
70. I've never seen him 60 pounds it's
such a shame dude 38 years old such a
nice guy by the way
great guy such a bummer great guy man
that bums me up really I know it's such
a bomber man it's such a shame
wow
what can you do man yeah like DC said it
sometimes life doesn't seem fair it's
just such a [ __ ] bummer it's usually
uh popped up usually kids have issues
with this yeah not grown adults yeah and
especially hit it yeah I don't know who
knows you know people they'll be my
steroids this no no listen listen uh
this happens my friend is on his last
he's 38 same thing and he just got
cancer and you know it just happens man
it's just what happens it's called
genetics I know or they'll figure out
they'll be the one they'll be like you
know mayonnaise when you eat it with
lemon what you know some weird thing who
knows it's such a bummer dude yeah man
it really is but well that's the show um
but I want to just break down the
chamber I believe you guys I guess I'm
gonna say this about so I I had money on
Poirier
and no disrespect to the great Michael
Chandler but I will say this
and I am not in a position to say
anything about someone's technique
especially a guy like Michael Chandler
however I nerd out on striking and I
watch Boxing and
and when I saw how wide his stance was
initially coming out and I and I know
what what uh Dustin does to your lower
calf I was like is he baiting him in or
is he not I think Chandler always fights
low like this okay so exposed for the
double and the power right now would you
say that he throws those he throws with
I mean the explosiveness and you can get
in trouble but it feels like whoever a
striking coach was if you're going to
throw those looping shots and that's
what Dustin said but also with your
hands down
and you're leaning in against a guy like
Dustin Poirier it's like I have to say
whoever is striking coach is it's like
you had to have you have to be able to
see that that's a liability well I made
a striking coach one of the best in the
world uh who is this striking coach is
the guy who's at the black zillions he
works with I mean everybody so oh um um
okay literally world class yeah yeah one
of the best in the world sure but like
so it's so maybe it's just but that's
that's not why he lost me
there's nobody lost at all what do you
mean he didn't lose because he had a
white stance he lost his he got punched
in the face a lot right well but that's
again that's not a technique thing from
heaven but but no but it but it's it's
that that's challenging it's a it's an
error on Chandler's part it's just how
Chandler fights like that's like telling
you know but that's not gonna get you
that's gonna be a major liability when
you're fighting people in top five major
liability I mean yeah and that it
appears that way but also but that's
that's what got him to the dance that's
why you saw the performance of the of
the knights you know yeah so it's like
yeah at that at that top level and also
challenge teams gonna have to figure out
because he's dominating these first
rounds like Charles Oliveira 10-8 yeah
Tony Ferguson did work but doesn't pray
I was like holy [ __ ] this is me a long
life it doesn't pour it like out wrap
them pick them up slam them down now
second round was just a you know
gangbusters
but the difference was to your point
when it came down technique Dustin will
fancy himself a cockfight as far as like
in a phone booth but he's still throwing
straight shots Chandler goes it's not
even Chandler's events world champion
world champion but I mean I think that's
what that's what Chandler does technique
like really correct technique comes in
like instead Channel's just he like I'm
sorry poor a when the when the bullets
are flying is one of the best we've ever
seen which stays focused because they're
both Landing yeah but Porey had more
precise was laying in better spots and
then really it's a lot of it it was with
the grappling like same thing with
Charles Oliveira uh Chandler made
mistake grappling with Dustin parade
made a mistake yeah so then once you
know and he's tired too because he's so
explosive and he blows his wad in that
first round so he's gonna have to
recalibrate yeah you know because yeah
that's two two out of here I think he
got choked out because he was so tired
I think it was great it was great
technique yeah he was dealing with
amazing technique yeah the black belt so
the way I want to discredit boy like
that or or Chandler yeah because the way
he took his back and originally and he
knew the blood it's a black belt move he
had it on his cheek yeah so what did he
do it was under his chin yeah this but
then with with the blood it's gonna slip
in there is that what it is yeah yeah so
that's super hot yeah so so when he
pushed his chin over you know exactly
what he's doing it's just a matter of
time he's going to fit in yeah and then
once he he repositioned the blood yeah
so sneaky so good yeah I love Jiu-Jitsu
on that it's just so fun to watch that
yeah
um what do you feel about the if
somebody puts their fingers in your
mouth
I'm biting their fingers off again I
think he did yeah I would too oh I mean
you're not playing the piano again but
also yeah also Chandler he was like I I
couldn't see I didn't know he's like
maybe I didn't know I was grabbing yeah
I I give him the benefit of the doubt
Chandler's a [ __ ] stand-up
[ __ ] you know yeah I mean it's a
technique it's a dirty move but I don't
think gentleman he's not dirty fighter
no no no I'm gonna do that I'm gonna
give you his nose was clogged and he
blow him be like oh even that's dirty
chair's like I think Craig
they can [ __ ] breathe but for
challenge I hate people this team's
gonna have to recal calibrate because
you know we love him he's getting these
performance of the knights but he's not
winning and the UFC holds that over your
head well when it comes to negotiation
so you know great fight search we love
him if I'm if I'm if I'm I'm saying to
him you are so explosive and I would
take a look at where when you're
throwing this hands down with a guy like
like you know or you're throwing those
looping shots you're gonna get punched
in the face and vanderly silver was was
crushing people because he would throw
but he would throw this way and got once
guys like striking coaches were like
just just fire down the middle you're
gonna catch him that's just physics and
that's that's basically what Dustin said
so guys who can sit in the cut weather
that storm if you can which is a big if
for a lot of guys but if you're as good
as you know uh Poirier and then you know
that's gonna that's gonna win it it's
gonna win it what you don't agree no I
do I I would never give Michael Chandler
advice on how to throw punches
I know it's tough because it it's
Michael Channel like even with but I'm
kind of right
I mean I am I mean call him and tell if
we're no never dude no oh my God
you don't think he knows this I don't
you can't you I'm sure he knows I'm sure
like his fight going into Justin gaichi
fight his plan was to get him to commit
and then shoot doubles challenge has
that thing where it's he doesn't give it
no no can I just say this about it he's
a dog he knows his whole team knows
everything about it they're smarter than
us what I would say is this what I guess
what I'm trying to say is this
because he's a wrestler and been a
wrestler his whole life and such a great
wrestler maybe there is a tendency when
you go when you know when when the In
the Heat of the Moment everybody goes
back to their happy place maybe there's
this idea when you're a wrestler your
hands automatically are there to protect
your hips you're there you're almost
going down to protect you're doing too
long because I'm a world champion
it's all down well I can give you
situations within the Pierre fight is he
fight with their hands are down
sometimes [ __ ] happens but those guys
are so high level Strikers first their
hands are still down but they're
Strikers first and I think with a
wrestler it's well look let's put it
this way I'm kind of right because it's
not working right I mean it's working
but not at the top top level so I think
if I'm his coach if I'm going back to
the drawing board that has to be a
conversation it just does Yeah
It's just tough to change the DNA yeah
but you have to yeah it depends what
Corey wants to do because what they have
to do is those first rounds are that I
don't know there's only half the people
you're gonna make out of this first
round correct that's why anybody else
not in the top threes not gonna that's
what I'm saying but but he has but he's
going to be a champ or B like you know
it's yeah it depends what he wants to do
if you want to still be exciting you
know that's his thing it's tough dude I
don't know he's also you know what did I
say to you what did I say to you I
texted you I was like I'm so glad you're
out of MMA in a way there's in a way
it's an it's there's a no-win situation
in general right okay tough kids right
it's like it's beautiful there's there's
Glory but I don't know man I'm just you
know I I would imagine you watch this
and just go
not anymore no I'm entertained yeah I
love watching I do too and then with
Poirier too it's like I wonder what's
next for him because they gotta you know
I think Fourier just needs to need to be
fantastic in general in other words
don't worry about Market Chef let's not
worry about that let's just get through
here
yeah well that's going to be a tough
long tough one but
I mean especially coming off this fight
so he's such a big name they probably
want that you know sit in the car he
only wants big fights too so you know I
don't know but then also it's like do
the high profile fights you know what
but who's high profile that's what he
wants Colby Covington just Grudge
matches now just get those guys you
train with throw on 70 that's tough and
then for Kobe he's trying to fight mock
Jeff you know so that's not gonna happen
no Kobe's trying to fight uh comes on
right yes yes sorry sorry yeah yeah uh
yeah so so you know what if you're
Dustin you don't fight dead that's what
I would out chill Darius is the fight
for Dustin by the way but if you don't
know stereo should wants to fight Dustin
Dustin doesn't need it right there he is
well Dustin and really like you want a
huge name fight like you want that Nate
Diaz you want something he's coming off
the car money his level money sit back
or is it does he only have one left so
is he gonna go out on a shield and fight
mock absolutely not 100 we don't need to
do that I know there's no upside that
[ __ ] off he's done it all he's fantastic
he's beautiful just let him just be cool
man I know he likes to chill too I don't
know if I was running the UFC nobody
would make money because I'd be like I
don't want to fight he's going to fight
Brian Callan Brian with uh 50 ounce
gloves well the thing about Frankie
Edgar last fight here fight Gutierrez
it's like what is that so Frankie
retired thank God I mean
you know and they're saying Frankie
picked him out all the guys well I don't
know who wasn't in his ear like bro
let's play like a dominant Cruz another
Legend thank you Ryan yeah not something
some up and coming ball of fast twitch
that can drive history
but he's you know that was a bummer to
see of course it was predictable oh yeah
but a bummer now now I'll tell you um
I I'm excited who does uh yair Rodriguez
fighting for the intern build yeah
so for volkanasi it's like he is the
biggest kangaroo balls on the planet
even if let's say and I'm saying there
let's say the odd makers are right
matcha mops the floor with them
all right so then you go back to 45 and
you're fighting another big fight for
the interim you know you're fighting the
guy who has a belt yeah Rodriguez and
Josh Emmett I want to see the I want to
see yair Rodriguez fight Volk that's
going to be very interesting to me I
think he's the one guy that can be in
football I'm gonna put my money on your
yard let's put it that way well I
wouldn't I I I just I don't see anyone
hardly hard to fight I don't think
anybody's being bulkhead 45. I'm just
seeing why he did uh Max I believe see
what Max did to yeah I don't think so
yep
provoked though business is booming you
have the super fight mock Jeff in your
hometown business and then even if you
were to lose that heaven forbid then you
just fall back fight for another tied up
say it 45. No One's Gonna you know hang
it over your head you lost a [ __ ]
mock again there's nothing wrong with
being at the top at 45 for as long as
you need to I don't know what that
weight Cut's like for God that card is
that Whitaker podcast on Whitaker Apollo
Justin Tyson Pedro that's a fun fight uh
I think that uh Wei Lee is going to be
uh champ for a while yeah yeah it's her
time she looked good huh
she looked good I don't know oh you're
thinking some
dabbling in a little bit of uh
gear sauce and we're not talking about
the orange sauce from PF Changs
we'll talk about that are you talking
about that good good I don't know what
you're talking about you don't think you
you know I see what you're insinuating
he thinks she's artificially creating a
Chinese lab do I think the Chinese
no come on no their Olympic teams clears
I don't know what you're saying no they
would never I don't know I mean I think
that the Russians and Chinese would
never yeah she's uh
but I'll tell you what a hell of a
champion
halibut Champion as far as the story is
cool too because she won the BET like
eight years ago on The Ultimate Fighter
coming back now she got the belt again
being Rose and then you know now she
fought way lay and that's his that's his
and as far as it's as good as you get
without
like with uh coaching and good nutrition
um
that's his but I see what you're doing
here well you know what I don't like out
of you hey is that Mark Harley oh no
that's
sorry I know I just saw them muscles on
the on her biceps they need they need
some new blood up in there you know what
I'm saying like it's been the same girls
and Joanna Rose
um you know all the the same four or
five girls just been rotating around
yeah you know was it limos she she can
do it just beat Rodriguez or yeah yep
that is uh
that's going to be she's going to be
she's a prom because not because
remember she puts on the scene just
knocking girls out now her grappling's
really good I mean she may she may you
may see and don't you normally get that
good at grappling this short
a world-class scrapple and then to take
[ __ ] Carlos bars down and then submit
her like that at a high level see what
the thing is dude Carla all she does is
because because she's lifting weights
and PR and dedicated and practicing
really hard now what you what I think
you're going to see eventually is a
super fight with Whaley and uh
my girlfriend Chef jenko yeah
the bullet and uh the bullets that'd be
interesting I mean Waylon needs to go on
a run in order to get that she has to be
probably I'd say just two more girls
there's really no one for a chef chanker
you like the range right and Chef senko
I would imagine is probably a lot bigger
right taller taller yeah in the ship
drink or can wrestle too though uh but
waylas her ass off Willie's a problem
she's a problem
she's a problem five five not much
taller uh but she's probably but um you
know problem yeah well you're you know
you're having it's it's it's
that's a good fight that's a good fight
it's a jawline
she's I'd love to see her get her hands
on you what if I had her on food truck
she comes in just beat the [ __ ] out of
you I would be I would be wrong kissing
her ass I admire her very much I think
she's an amazing no no don't go back on
it that's it don't be that guy that's
that's a
the only person that beats her is Rose
how old is she correct how old is she
17. 33 she's seven thirty three can I
see pictures of Wendy's Yang when she
was 23. okay I see what you're doing
here I'm asking a question why can't I
have this plates more dates what are you
trying to do here dude all I'm doing is
asking some questions she's always been
kind of stocky yeah
has she
her face looks a little more narrow here
that's it hmm does it
keep scrolling down how old is she there
can't tell
yeah her face is more narrow what her
arms look um and then like compared to
this Carlos
um
no I don't know I'm not saying anything
I'm just saying
and I would I would assume she's big
over in China right if you're having a
UFC champ oh yeah
um I'm sure I'm sure that there's no
yeah Pride going on there yeah look man
she's awesome and she is I I'm I'm being
silly right now but no you're not done
you're not done it's all right buddy I
can be excused I think I can be excused
for oh my God I'm noticing yeah noticing
a a very big
difference in
even her skill set though I mean the her
Grandpa and wrestling Jesus she's going
for the single legs she's unbelievable
I'm a problem the only one who beat her
really is a huge problem is Rose is like
your Achilles heel but uh yeah who knows
athletic greens is what I gotta say an
ag1 it's cold flu season popping right
now and I get sick every December but
you gotta get your fruits and vegetables
you gotta get one tasty scoop of ag1
because it contains 75 vitamins minerals
Whole Foods sorts ingredients
multivitamin multi-mineral probiotic
green superfood blend and More in one
convenient daily serving the special
blend of high quality bioavailable and
that's important yeah
dude this flu cold season we're heading
into your boy can't afford to get sick
and here's the thing join the movement
of athletes lifelights podcast Comics
moms dads stepmom billionaires
billionaires sure to make it easy I like
greens and give you immune support and
free one-year supply of vitamin D really
important right now and five free travel
packs with their first purchase is if
you visit athleticgreens.com fighter
right now again all you gotta do is go
to athleticgreens.com fighter to take
control of your health and give ag1 a
try you got to improve your Alpha Waves
you got to be able to improve your
memory and your focus I'm talking about
alphabetes you're talking about the
nootropic talking about Alpha Brain from
on it yes nootropics only people I trust
man I guess who else trusts Alpha Brain
our friend Joe Rogan you want to be like
Jason every day huh he's the he's the
scroogee take it every time we do a
podcast I take it every I've been on it
for years yes before was the cool trendy
thing to do right so over a million
bottles over a million bottles and if
you're a little you know worried about
getting jittery from the the caffeine
here's the thing it's caffeine free
that's correct matter of fact our
friends at Anna are so positive you're
in love Alpha Brain you can get your
money back yep keep no refunding no
refund no questions that's fun man so
save 10 off your order by going to
audit.com f-a-t-k you save 10 not only
on Alpha Brain but also the entire right
you got Warrior bars protein powders
fish oils everything kettlebells
freaking battle ropes we got it all on
it.com f-a-t-k you can say to himself
your nootropic at out with Alpha Brain
or you can swing by your local Walmart
and just pick up some Alpha Brain but go
to audit.com
f-a-t-k now let's get back to the
program Brian yeah
and all our friends did you have uh
I had a fomo because all our buddies
were in New York was there schultzy Theo
Jared Leto like all our friends are
there you know yeah well at fomo
everyone was out there we didn't get
invited so we couldn't go though sure we
couldn't go that's a square garden about
to go to mass Square Garden watch those
five I've walked by it I've never been
there oh it's pretty cool yeah no it's
cool I've been I've been to fights there
yeah I did the when I when did the press
conference for that crocop fight because
it was in uh New Jersey but the Press
counts at Radio City Hall it's pretty
cool
yeah oh yeah never met Square Garden
pretty cool where do we watch the fight
when you did the
is Matt matron Fedor in New York was it
in New York did we watched the fight oh
[ __ ] I worked magic worker so that is
MSG there oh yeah that sounds like I've
been there there's nothing special now I
think about it it's all right that was
all up in now I was gonna say once you
get there it's like it's like it's a
motorcycle I'll tell you what's nuts is
uh sofa and the players don't like
playing it because they say it doesn't
feel it doesn't have that same
atmosphere right because the technology
is so insane oh right and then a rat
like the bowl where it's like you know
not eye level but right above the
players it's new it's [ __ ] it's like
you're an avatar like people so they're
below you people eating Nobu Sushi like
it's and they're like you're feeling are
they below you or they're in eye level
what do you mean well it's like they're
barely below but right there's like all
like the sweets oh gotcha gotcha and
then the screen is bigger than the
studio it just it doesn't feel like that
football atmosphere so yeah players
don't like it yeah like if you like you
know you're like entertainment you know
but people are really there it's La too
and you know the Rams left came back so
there's like that weird like loyal fan
base yeah it's a weird vibe man that is
weird I can't understand super weird
vibe
did you uh watch uh season five of
Yellowstone sir I did not watch season
five I did watch a large part of killer
Sally
uh oh yeah yeah yeah the bodybuilder
yeah and I I I sympathize I don't think
she's on steroids either no but I simply
admit for her he was a monster he had
five different steroids in his body and
he was he basically beat the [ __ ]
[ __ ] out of her and the kids her nose
and stuff like the kids yeah and the
kids so after a while when her own son
said I was relieved as I stepped over
his body isn't that crazy I'm like well
that guy was a monster
I know so why'd she do 25 [ __ ] years
well they were saying if it happened now
she'd have a better defense because
we're more you know educated and
enlightened on domestic violence how it
works yeah she was a victim
the only problem with that is the way
she killed him she shot him and then
reloaded or something and and it was
like she said he was running at her but
they went over like the kind of you know
the actual fact of it where the way she
shot him and that yeah the ballistics
then went back reload the shotgun shot
him in the face when you know it's weird
but well you know it's like she probably
had so much resentment and anger from
all the years yeah once you pull that
trigger you're trying to kill that
mother she did 25 hard oh Sean with a
shotgun buddy yeah yeah well I think
it's [ __ ] up that uh last time yeah I
do I think that that the guy was trying
to kill her she was aggressive too
though right like I'm with you I don't
think you should do 20 years when you
get beaten up enough times that way and
you think you're gonna die and this
guy's choking you oh it breaks her she
was the kids too [ __ ] off especially
with the kids nah that guy was in a bad
abuser and hitting the kids too so
everybody was terrified of him that's a
monster in your house but and did you
get to the part yet where they take her
into the station because she calls she
has shot my husband taking the station
and they're they're too sad oh there's
dude this is the size part they're
sitting there in the waiting room
waiting for the cops that's when I turn
it on the sun girls no the Sun Goes mama
just let him know self-defense like he
was trying he's horrible he's trying to
kill us she's like I know that's what
I'm gonna say she goes but I'm gonna
have to go to trial so you guys are
going to see me for a while and he's
crying he's well Mama just tell him like
he was trying to hurt I can't handle
that and she was like I I trust me I am
sometimes it doesn't work like that
buddy I can't imagine the pain she went
through
yeah so you don't get to see your kids
really for 25 years or raise them think
about that the state's going to raise
them enjoy that yeah kids are pretty
messed up too like the sun is an addict
right he is yeah he's trying he just got
a rehab on the thing he was like you
know I struggle with you know drugs and
of course it's tough of course he but
they both won the military too just like
their mama and wow step daddy
man those tough to watch it's good
though it's a good watch but she was
super aggressive too though not that
that means anything I'm just saying she
had some wrestle yet 60 years old
doesn't look bad for 60 dude no it ends
because you won't watch it and then she
gets remarried oh that's good black dude
good all right was it his friend no just
some dude she met I think at the thing
some older black dude and the older
black guy was funny he was like yeah my
friend's like hey you know what she's
John's Church
oh yeah all right and drug addiction wow
and look look even the daughter she's
her genetics are no punk either look how
big her shoulders 100
yeah and she suffers from two she
because she she served too in Iraq and
she was in an abusive relationship yeah
you repeat that trauma yes you're
attracted yeah that's why that like when
when a man does that to a household it
it's like the reverberations can ruin a
generation after generation
yeah it's called tiller salads on
Netflix
yeah you really I wish you were on to
Yellowstone it's so [ __ ] I will watch
it oh man it's good I will watch it it's
so good you want to come to Detroit with
me
okay and it's cold there right now I
mean
four degrees Milwaukee is not well
you're gonna be right there with me
buddy I know not too far away and I got
Addison Addison Improv this weekend that
won't be cold nothing won't be cold oh
it's in the 50s Texas Dallas
uh destroys four well 35 in the morning
that's been nice crisp yeah 40s no snow
though 40 is not great though but it's
not great you're not gonna need a parka
this is true but I'm gonna bring one
anyway
it's just easier boy at night he gets a
little dice you guys shooting at night
no I think it's daytime I think what
movie is this buddy it's a good movie
it's uh
you'll see it when it comes out and it's
Tom Cruise in it too yeah
it's black panther three in Detroit you
guys are the white devils and I play
um I play Henry Ford yes I play at
Panther I play the white panther you're
an albino Panther you're the you're the
bad guy I'm the bad guy I'm actually the
albino Panther that's sickly because I
have I don't have the genetics and I'm
just I I have asthma I have I mean
brains of it I'm I'm the brain yes
you're the brains I won't even say that
because now you're making the white guy
the brands that's very very racist well
no you're the brains of and you're
ordering other people not black or white
they're trying to backtrack right now no
I'm not you're easy but you but you
can't be you can't be
the villain the movie not be the brain's
operation that's true you got to be like
yeah I will come up with the plan yeah
exactly yes with my claws yeah but
you're right
straight white and like this I'm like
does anybody have any good coffee yeah
yeah that Detroit fights no punk dude
it's raining and snowing for the next
couple days in Detroit oh that's great I
can't [ __ ] wait you should have to
sell tickets tonight so if you need me
guys I'll be in Detroit bro you should
have seen my security at specs Mark how
seriously that's security side the
appearance suspects like they're big
I go to get out right and it's people
like outside the door and I see the
security I got out and the lady run it
organizing goes okay you ready what
happened why is there all the security
that's for you like oh I don't I don't
need this like this is what we just with
everybody dude I'm talking big like
Special Forces boys private security
like I was looking I just hope something
pops off so I can see you boys in work
the real deal holyfields but they were
telling me I was like well who's here
performing because clearly getting
security for the other people said Conor
McGregor was there recently P Diddy DJ
Khaled you need some security yeah they
had and uh who else oh the milk boys
were there who were massive right so
they have all these big people there I
said who's the coolest and the guy was
like P Diddy was weird because this rock
thing you know you guys said there's a
line like 300 people waiting for him
he'll say hey look Hey where's your
bathroom at okay it's like back there
cool just walk down the back door kind
of Scar and left no [ __ ] I was like
where'd Pete did he go wow just
disappeared good to see it just kept
going yeah sometimes you just want to
deal this is the craziest One with DJ
Khaled really yeah they're like more
people shove him for than anyone yeah
they're like just chasing his car like
the DJ damn I'm not nuts yeah I'll see
all those people you think it'd be like
a Connor or no kidding Kevin Hart
something like that no DJ Khaled he said
crazy Madness
shape Madness
booze booze booze on booze booze on
booze anything we should know what he
got current let's get into current
events sure before daddy gets on a plane
um let's see here I just saw this one
stand up oh this is great yeah so Cobra
died after a boy bit it it was wrapping
around the boy's arm so the kid bit it
two times dude that's impressive smarter
the kid I guess that's a kid he's eight
years old
them choppers on him too he just bit
into that body
gotta bite a snake if a bite snake bites
you you bite it back yeah give a little
snake a little dose of it it was like
when uh when GSP was fighting Johnny
Hendricks and um and you lost that fight
okay and he goes I tore my groin no he
was fighting Chaco Alves I think he goes
and Greg Jackson goes then hit him with
your groin yeah
snake tries to bite you you bite it back
on the top but it said the snake that's
the Cobra's was it a cobra cobra cobras
don't they're not uh
they still do it
you know what
you never know look at my face right now
I got skeptical hippos Cobras have
neurotoxins and blood toxic they're yeah
the snake got wrapped around my hand and
bit me I was in great pain as the
reptile didn't budge when I tried to
Shake It Off I bit it hard twice it all
happened in a flash it might have been
there ah maybe hold on I didn't know
look he suffered a dry bite I mean
there's no Venom yeah stay seen control
their venom yeah and so you know the
rumor forever was like oh baby
rattlesnakes are more dangerous because
they have more Venom no they're more
dangerous because they don't know like
um snake knows how to control its venom
yeah so it's not wasting it yes but
these These Old veterans yeah this real
veteran cover that that young boy
murdered
damn at least 934 people kill them
are you [ __ ] kidding me that 134
people died that's very sad I don't want
to watch that
but this is also really cool um so this
photographer he was with a group
on a tour and then there's an avalanche
going on and it looks like it's Outreach
what's that and it looks like it's not
going to reach you yeah until it does
this is just set the camera up early
maybe
so it goes over the camera yeah this is
wild I remember so they already took off
so he's just watched but this is insane
so I was like ah okay this is cool let's
just watch that
let's watch this that's that looks just
like water
and that's still far away are you
[ __ ] kidding me though maybe you
zoomed in but yeah he zoomed in coming
and it's coming
correct me if I'm wrong at 100 miles an
hour
it's weird because it looks nice out it
does and it also looks like it's
gonna stop anytime soon
but will we know it's not gonna come
it's not gonna stop
[Music]
oh dear God
foreign
but then at some point he started not
being able to breathe that well because
of all the yeah oh wow and all oxygen is
taken away yeah right they say this but
he was fine
well or die it's hard didn't I say dig
out and spit
so you know which is up enough people
know which way is up and down they dig
themselves deeper and then they're super
okay so what do you do you spit they
know which is down and which is up
and they crawl you know up the way oh
wow because a lot of people you don't
you're turning around you're like I
think this is a top and they keep
climbing down discombobulated they say
to spit and go the opposite [ __ ] a
the more you know I'm already
claustrophobic all right
I just saw this this is gonna be this
freaking this thing's video Zaman one
has a ton of fun videos
[Music]
that's pretty crazy it's just two not
that's like his girlfriend right she's
just flew me Boom by the way it's it's
that could have ended pretty bad I know
I just want to show you this real quick
this is a stupid Trend I don't know
who's doing this but there's an actual
pan it's a pan right it's on a ceiling
fan and you blindfold yourself yeah
oh [ __ ]
how bored are people and it's so dumb
too
that guy in the maroon thing's about to
get caught they're all girls wow
[ __ ] that I'm not interested in any of
that
anyways it was dumb yeah no okay that's
being very bored yeah listen there are a
lot of people that spend a lot of time
doing stuff that's not gonna like you
have a limited time in the day and you
know you can spend a lot of time doing
figuring out conspiracy theories and
spending a lot of time proving the Earth
is flat or you could get good at
something instead of doing it but they
were just maybe going for the views yeah
they're going for the views they might
have made some money on the views that's
but even when you get views on Graham I
can't see your face so what's the point
you got to be smarter about getting
views but anyway well the most dramatic
reverse entry there's also a little
older but it's really cool you know Ken
Block he's a professional okay so this
is they shut down uh the Las Vegas Strip
for this
hold this car going
looks like a Supra oh this guy's
actually in control of it all oh yeah
Ken Block's a mastermind damn
[Applause]
doesn't Ken Block oh yeah he's uh he's a
he drives the carts too right yeah
everything but he's also a NASCAR guy or
what no not NASCAR that's one
a lot of drifting stuff there's another
one here too it's like one of the
fastest spins
I don't like I mean I like Ken Block
that's cool
I mean he's one of the best drivers
you know good you gotta be not to hit
into those trails and [ __ ] crazy under
that controls nuts I thought it was a
Supra but it's an Audi
um real quick it says the crap hit at
the worst time
[Music]
oh you [ __ ] have it you just got that
right now no you did not do that no you
did not that's great
that's a big man upstairs Tony don't do
it buddy
[Applause]
don't cry bro don't you [ __ ] cry dude
that's not it's not your job to cry you
might be crying because the cramps
[ __ ] suck it up because otherwise I'm
gonna think you're crying over the The
Proposal that also might be a sign from
God that's probably not for the timing
all right Marcus hold on Mark's always
coming in with the with the heat
woman beats her neighbor with a hundred
ten pound meat stick that's pretty good
I would beat you with a [ __ ] meat
stick I'd love to do that I might I'd
like to see you swallow this meat sticks
you try making me and I'll pull it off
and beat you with it
no I'll let your meat stick like that
steak that [ __ ] thing of us doing
Jiu-Jitsu old school remember I'm gonna
post it I love it
um so I guess this woman went up to her
neighbor at Walmart hit it with a 10
pound leg of ground b or log of ground
beef okay uh and she'd previously the
victim had previously gotten a
restraining order against the suspect
before she moved away from the
neighborhoods imagine moving away from
this person being like I'm gonna get a
restraining order I'm gonna move and
then she's still stalking you at Walmart
with a 10 pounds there's no video of it
no one got video for business girls
asking me it all happened so quickly
the suspect was the most frozen ground
up Burger sticks yeah you really do
sometimes yeah
you'll try and then I'll [ __ ] counter
it like Dustin Poirier does and then I
come right back with my own meat stick
and it's always right here Florida man
allegi poured bleach and his co-workers
drink at Dollar General because it was
difficult because he was difficult to
work with yeah that's not going to work
out for anybody yeah including the
person drinking it you ever think about
doing that to some people who you work
with yeah when you taste please you're
like what yeah who seemed like man
that's right
wrong time
this is an old clip but I just it's been
circulating around
right next to the drink cart and that
happens it's so bad that it up turns
everything
oh my gosh
that's terrifying well that's not what
you're looking for Southwest but I can
give you the extra Peach you're so sorry
for that not fun and that's why you keep
your seatbelt on because people break
their neck yeah I think they're getting
vouchers yeah but also uh why is the
drink cart going on during turbulence I
guess maybe that is unexpected yeah but
usually they know or here they'll tell
you but you hit a pocket stream yeah you
can't control it
all right this one
so these are the NFL quarterbacks women
and the challenges how many beers would
it take for you to hook up with them
none uh Sarah Wilson no beer she's
adorable how many beers would it take to
get with NFL QBs oh they're QBs as well
oh that's what it is
she looks a lot like I mean Zach
Wilson's he came from BYU first round
draft pick okay well she's pretty so
they're ready
Stafford's a cutie pie so you know one
beer she's very pretty very pretty
[Applause]
100 percent
um
100 silver yeah yeah gravel is a dying
piece
oh wow
oh gosh
nah it's not a trap
okay that's the case that's at least the
case yeah one case wow seven beers Sean
Watson seven years they did they did
DeSean Watson bad though oh it's
terrible looking well that's that oh
Aaron Rodgers Aaron they made it look
older right that is not attractive those
are funny though
I know damn we gay huh got gas that's a
that's a that's a wide mouth but that's
someone said bro hell no that's just
Kirk with a wig on yeah he does look
identical there's no effort in that one
none yeah that was it of those let me
see Kirk Cousins and Kirk Cousins he
looks identical about it oh really they
did nothing though they just put a wig
is that true that's him if he grew his
hair out
it's hilarious
God they're balling they beat the bills
yeah
um worst blunt of all time worst blunt
rotation of all time oh so somebody said
this is the absolute nightmare blunt
rotation we've got Amy Schumer Jada
Pinkett Smith Amber Heard and Jared Leto
oh why they saw us some people might
disagree is what I'm saying uh why would
Jared let alone because you don't want
to swap like you don't want to be you
don't want them talking about you want
to be high with them I guess is my
what would the high conversation look
like Jared Leto that does he's fine had
a great conversationalist but
he was with the Theo right but I don't
think he's very close to each other what
about the rest of them
yeah
I wouldn't want to hear from him yeah
yeah those three he shouldn't be in
there sounds stressful if I'm Jared Leto
I'm like what the [ __ ]
must plan to end free lunch at Twitter
headquarters claims the meals cost 13
million a year wow he I'll tell you what
though with with Twitter what he's doing
it with the verification thing for eight
dollars so people are just verifying
random accounts [ __ ] businesses up
it's like people are like yo we're
giving out free whatever so the
stockholders can't tell the difference
so they're you know they're selling
their stocks and it's not good man he
needs to get a hold of that
right oh yeah there was just a little
dicey because if anybody can do it then
you don't know what's real what's not
this pharmaceutical company they they
verified and said oh good news insulin
is going to be free and then they're
worth plummeted by like a billion
dollars yeah it's not real maybe it's
not good
um I just with Elon it's just you know
you like the free speech thing but then
he almost needs to have someone who's
there but I would run it like more like
this dude you can't eight dollars
anybody gets verified because he's doing
it right to so those people those
journalists they tied behind their blue
check all right I think it's a question
of how you
yeah they're probably trying to figure
it out and what do you think about the
free meal thing like do you think when
you go to work at a tech company like
this they have all these incredible
perks you know notorious a place like
Google do you think
if you're making a certain salary there
like the lunch is on you
or do you think that should be expected
at any high level tech company if you
want them there and he's talking about
them working 40 hours a lot of stuff
like probably cover meals especially how
much money Twitter makes or used to make
yeah you know I wouldn't I wouldn't what
I wouldn't do if I'm Elon I'm not asking
him to work more hours and then cut the
benefits right that's not good I
understand you got to make profit but
Jesus Christ dude Elon put false Twitter
spend such a million you're on food
server for the San Francisco headquarter
in record show Peak uh I believe musk
100 and Tracy Hawkins doesn't want to
work for Elon Musk okay he's the bad guy
now interesting yeah you gotta be
careful because the left is making the
Elon not to be this villain hilarious
Whoopi Goldberg's I'm leaving Twitter
for a safe space anymore we don't
Twitter where you use it I don't get to
I don't get to hear Whoopi Goldberg's
tweets
hmm
alrighty
Arizona teacher I guess uh what are
these situations where she's filming
only fans content in her classroom with
her husband who's also a teacher at an
elementary school in fourth grade
killing two birds one stone yeah exactly
because you're on that teacher's salary
you get summons off so quick complain
but you've done that teacher's salary
and then she's also an only fans I I you
could come on is that her whoever hired
her the nose piercings of course you can
do this
so she's straight up shooting pornos on
the desk I guess so yeah what'd you
think was gonna happen
I've seen a lot of porno stuff right for
real no I mean that's so bad what did I
say what happened who said what you said
she's not hot oh yeah I think it's kind
of I was kidding okay oh okay sorry yeah
I mean you'd have to know these are
people who are so dumb you don't think
you're gonna get caught do you don't
think there's a better way or place to
it or maybe they just wanted to do it
because a gimmick but like I chose an
anonymous name as well as blocking the
entire State of Arizona on only fans so
it wasn't accessible to anyone living in
the state people are gonna see they're
gonna find out I mean listen if that's
my son's teacher I'm like what ah and
then also you go now is it just the fact
that they filmed it in her classroom or
like would any only no teachers are
screwed yeah the teachers that get
caught they they fire them like the
parents don't get down with it you kind
of have to fire them
no but this one yes you can't [ __ ] on
the desk where you teach students
[ __ ] math but the other one yeah
other teachers who are doing it from
their homes that are just there's some
teachers are super bodied up making like
a million bucks off only yeah and the
school's like we don't like this you're
out it's like what
it's not fair it's the kitchen see it
yeah
who are the teachers that are bodied up
oh there's a bunch of one only fans yeah
all right this one Mark Texas teacher on
leave after saying white people are
superior race now the racist teachers
just on leave but the one that was
having sex on the desk you got fired
actually
that's sex for you yeah we listen to the
clip which means I think my race is the
superior one I'm ethnocentric he says
the white is better than all no let me
finish
I think everybody thinks that they're
just not honest with them hey I'm not
racist though I like all types of
comments
yourself
[Music]
I think what he's trying to say I think
he was trying he's trying to keep it
real with these kids
why would he say this to those kids I
think he was trying to teach the kids
that everybody he's trying to give them
a lesson about how human beings are
tribal and racist no everybody has a
little he's that's what the super woke
actually want you to see if you're
anti-racist you have to first admit that
this is the anti-racist philosophy this
is not this is not him he's been reading
it's in Kennedy's terrible book how to
be in that Tyrese says deep down my
heart um so so Kenny would say that
everyone is a racist and the reason
Ibrahim Kennedy calls black people white
supremists sometimes I can't assumes is
because they they are still profiting
and upholding the system
that would be the American system which
they believe was built on oppression
which is hilarious and so if you so so
if you if you are part of the system
then you have to admit you're racist
that's what everyone can that's the
central theme of Abram Kennedy's Book
I've read it terrible book yeah but I've
also read write white fragility even
worse book
um I've also read Derek Bell and all the
other critical race theorists and it's
just it's that's why they Advocate
tearing the system down because the
system is racist so what he's saying is
that that's the first admission to White
like to White uh what is it called White
abolitionist you have to be a white
abolitionist you have to be anti-white
sort of to say look I'm you have to
admit first that you're racist before
you can move on and he was trying to
have a teaching moment but he didn't he
wasn't able to yeah because that that's
where it stopped it's a little I don't
know well this is the left this is where
the left eats its own tail it's the way
it's the snake eating its own tail
this is what what happens this is a guy
who's actually trying to create a
teaching moment for his students gets
stopped before he finishes his thought
or sentence and now he's on
administrative leave because I'm usually
with you it's a little tough because
they go hold on so it's in the white
race is superior he goes yes all of you
and most people think he was trying to
say that everyone he said everyone from
their particular group in their heart is
going to have that bias about their yes
and so you have to come you have to
confront that first before we can move
on and have an honest conversation
around tribalism racism and how we have
we are inherently naturally tribal slash
racist or at least naturally human
beings that from an evolutionary point
of view are distrustful of things that
are different that's why yes that's why
when they showed pictures of like so
they show a picture of a black person
white people have a they have
assumptions that tend to be negative
compared to white person that's cetera
Etc interesting yeah
and that's this is all the work of
critical race theorists Ibraham candy
who's a lightweight teacher didn't know
that they were filming now
he must know them
he asked the kids to put their phones
down yeah and he's on he's only on leave
so maybe he'll be back I don't know oh
what the [ __ ] just how man uh giselle's
dating Joaquin Valente yeah the Valente
Brothers they're really close with uh
Huron and Hannah oh she's a great guy I
don't know if she's dating him they're
just assuming because the kids were
there too he was also her Jiu Jitsu
instructor go ahead and say he is yeah
really nice guy
a little fast right I know the Inkster
weather but you don't know how long it's
been how long that's what they said
they've been celebrating for quite some
time we're just now getting private to
it that's tough
I mean do you have to go out the next
week though after we hear about him get
a man yeah but he's the juicy coach tall
thin guy not that tall no
oh there you go weird right he's a
really really nice guy sure
tie you up to huh oh yeah Savage yeah
good good on the mat good on the mat get
on the map not bad looks a little bit
like me looks a little bit like young
Brian Callan I'm not gonna lie to you a
little bit right could be related a
little bit your younger brother stating
Giselle
right let me wipe her up you're set
you're set yeah a lot of money you're
pregnant and he's breastfeeding him
right yeah so they're speaking in their
native tongue finally yeah there's a
connection there
and also yeah because that's training
with them once but thank you Valentine
Brothers
for making train so much fun
uh I'm looking forward to keep improving
let's go and then Brady reacted my dad's
leaving dishes in the sink are numbered
um he's aren't burning that dick in her
mouth
well you know it's a tough pill to
swallow yeah it's tough
but Tom Brady is the greatest of all
time and I wonder if he's going to have
trouble getting all these girls I know
yeah
we didn't say weed but girls hooked up
with him if he was a female yeah girl
Stone no there are girls into him I
don't know but are there girls that are
all available I know I don't know how
tall is he yeah
he's got no it doesn't have any money
what's this it's just I'd be pissed if I
was in tmzy and that's my picture
how's your security now are they
escorting a hound dog
Bradley driving his [ __ ] cheese is
that a hound dog
it looks like G-Wagon Jamie Foxx Jamie
Foxx
LeBron LeBron his wife that's his and
that's uh
Sammy raymie whatever
Leonardo does that well don't dress like
that but Leonardo DiCaprio does the damn
thing huh just doing it doing these
parties still not on social media
just doing his thing smart I know smart
huh
so smart stays just Out Of Reach he's
the king maker man oh my God what's his
dad
that's his dad this is dead yeah let's
dad's beard like there's mustache like
Hitler I know that's interesting
laying out just and that's his girl
right now is it Gigi she quit uh Twitter
she quit Twitter too yeah she was the
one who was like he's just become too
much of a toxic yeah has it ever been
really bad it's pretty toxic yeah
okay so I'm gonna go to alrighty I'm
gonna go to Detroit you wanna do your
dates right now then guys out of Sam
Prof I'll see you November 17 18 19
Naples Florida off the hook Comedy Club
December one two three have more energy
there than he did on this episode what
do you mean did I was like was that low
energy no we're not rushing low energy
you got Boston Massachusetts Live Boston
December 29 30 31 and I got four winning
Indiana January 12 13 14. wait what did
I say Wayne will be fun um
uh Milwaukee is this Friday Saturday
Milwaukee improv Friday Saturday only
two shows Friday two shows Saturday
Jeffrey Dahmer's Hometown Milwaukee and
then Providence Rhode Island the show's
almost sold out we might add a show
December 1st through the 3rd then
Washington DC DC Improv my favorite
clubs December 15th to the 17th Kamala
Harris has opened up for me there that's
cool uh yeah there you go Milwaukee
Providence Rhode Island Washington to
see that ends 2022 touring for the Ohi
thick tour but Milwaukee you're up this
Friday Saturday get your award-winning
tiger thick nectar from thickboy.com
that's it kids love you